I do a lot of Q&A I mean I think a lot
of you know pretty flattered by how many
people knew who I was so you want to go
whine you a little tech entrepreneurship
investing social 101 don't be
embarrassed I looked at a lot of people
that were tweeting about today's events
there's not that many experts so just
kidding just tell me your name yes ma'am
a summer I'm gonna repeat this right
good for the goose looks are pretty good
here yeah a little louder summer
giveaway
so who's your target audience that it's
almost like a b2b or like you're not
going to wreck with yeah yep
so are you're not mainly targeting 12 to
23 year olds
that's a [ __ ] line right I mean that's a
truth right you don't need to play there
right like the truth is not everybody
needs to be everywhere like if your
audience is not there now look here's
where people get caught people will be
there things kept going
look at into their the fastest growth in
Instagram is 40 year old female that's
not the news that I just saw the fastest
growing sector of individuals that are
taking selfies are 40 to 50 year old
women your mom is selfie so so a couple
things Instagram you need to be at and
so I look you need to figure it out look
um here's what's really interesting I'm
not good at Instagram for like I
understand what it takes to be good at
it
I'm not actually good at it because I
think we're all taking pictures I don't
think that way like I basically take
angry selfies of myself at the airport
and pictures of my sneakers I suck
right it's not what a storytelling
Twitter I'm good Facebook comes out
there's places where you could be good
and bad but let me tell you this there's
a couple things first and foremost you
need to understand hashtag culture the
most important thing for you to get
discovered especially now that Instagram
discovery has done personal you have to
get good at hashtag culture you do it
back home and search all the hashtag
data around the hashtags you need to be
using on every photo I guarantee if I
looked at all the photos you put out you
aren't putting enough hashtags in there
that are relevant to reach your audience
because once people get down the hashtag
rabbit hole that's how they can discover
you
that's number one number two you need to
figure out how to put out good Instagram
photos I don't know what that is it
might be infographics it might be I
don't know what it is for your business
I don't but you need to be testing and
you need to be also new homework like
you need to allocate 10 to 40 hours and
search successful Instagram accounts and
do data and search right and so like you
know it takes work and look Instagram is
still tough it's still very personal
it's not looking for businesses to be
done there as much people aren't calling
as many things as they did before
because they learn that lesson so the
bar is raised you got to be better the
other thing the other endeavor the other
thing that you really really really
really need to focus on is Pinterest I
will tell you right now with just on
top-line understanding of what you just
said you need to go all in on Pinterest
Pinterest is the holy grail for you and
it's a lot of work and you may have to
invest in a designer I don't know the
size your business but like you've got a
you've got a really cool beat if you
haven't read the chapter read the
chapter of the Pinterest but you need to
do way more homework than that the good
news is Pinterest just launched their
paid product so they have a new ad
product coming out I think it's gonna be
very very very well I would highly
recommend you google the crap out of
Pinterest business stuff over the next
month or two and really learning you got
it
gonna go to that she'll McPherson and
Perry calorie man Club good beard bro
yeah it's a great question uh you know I
always tell people I'm not mr. Thomas
right like I'm up for like I'm not this
great predictor I'm just reacting to
reality meaning way too many people are
like so obsessed with predicting the
next thing I'm not I start paying
attention to mine three weeks after
launched because it was in the top 15
top 20 of the iTunes free app store like
if people were using it it was worth my
time I mean people tell me like six
months ago somebody's like I don't know
about this Instagram it might be a fad
like 200 million people using like look
back right like are you out of your mind
so like here's what I do a couple of
basic things I read TechCrunch and tech
meme every morning just see if anything
launched from a good entrepreneur that's
one before
hi every morning the first thing I do
before I brush my teeth I've looked at
the iTunes & Android top 100 top 200
apps like I knew about you yak before
anybody else because there it was and
like I'm like okay what's this and like
I'm not scared of like jumping in and
figuring it out it's what I do I get my
hands dirty right like I play in the
clouds and in the dirt I'm thinking up
here and the second I see something that
has a chance of irrelevant I put in the
work and whether you yak disappears or
space forever I'm not worried because
right now is that enough scale that it
merits my attention if I want to be a
leader in understanding what it's about
and so it's not that hard
and there's Buffett now I have one other
slight advantage at this point in my
career that I used to not have which is
a I have a twenty five million dollar
seed fund that I do a nest thing through
and I've seen companies before they even
launched but to be very honest the
number of things I've seen that vehicle
in comparison to the thing everybody in
here can do which is open the top 200
apps on iTunes has been far less sunny
me you know I remember talking to like
all the digital leaders about one day lo
you know like is he months ago and
they're like what like nobody knew it
was because it was mainly targeting
nineteen year old girls at the time it
wasn't in TechCrunch or Mashable I don't
care about the press I care about the
user behavior and so I'm just looking
for places where I can see that behavior
right and nothing's better right now
than the app stores top lists of free
apps you just watch what people look I'm
looking at a company right now like we
heart it right like I'm looking at this
stuff and so you know you look at it and
you look at it you try the Sun people
leave it in no no I hate it because of
two things one I'm such an obnoxious
optimist that like the second like
something bad happens I forget about it
and make pretend it never happened
right I'm like good like that if you
speak pretty happy my biggest mistake
was in 2009 when I was transitioning off
of Wine Library TV Wine Library calm and
my brother nice part of vaynermedia and
I was writing crush it which was on its
way to becoming a big-time book and I
also start bought corked
which is a wine social network and I
started an obsessed TV which is like an
interview show that was similar to Wine
Library TV and I got the big guys I
tried to bite off more than I could chew
and sometimes when you're running five
businesses you're running none and I
learned my lesson
and I learned that if I was gonna do it
in the future I couldn't be the operator
in the business my partner had to be and
then I needed more money that I wasn't
like I could scrap it by but not
everybody has that ability and so my
biggest mistake hands down was in the
summer 2009 and my first daughter was
born and like I just decided to go and
stay there trying to do everything at
one time and there was too much and
things failed for the first time for me
mainly because I wasn't thriving them
and it's been great because now I've got
the new fund and were incubating
companies and I have a much better
chance of being successful with some
stuff I'm building right now mainly
because of
back at all night yes ma'am Oh in the
back I'm Caroline and how are you so I
look I'm very interested in the wine
world and I personally think it's one of
the most romantic markets out there it's
the best for stories and the best
probably the longest journey out there
so where do you see wine going in the US
I can speak to the US I'm asking
apologize I just don't know the markets
outside the US as well why isn't really
good spot America um you know we're past
the douchey phase you know 1970s 80's
90's did you drink wine you reduce right
and so you were fancy your snobby right
and then everybody else Frank wait
Centinela box wine there was just no
middle class and the middle class starts
emerging in the mid 90s and then the
Wine Spectator Robert Parker became the
engines that throw a wall of wine and
then look I'm very proud I think one of
the most proud things I'll have in my
legacy is there will be that Wikipedia
atrium when I started with my library TV
because when I started with Wine Library
TV became the preview to what was about
to happen in the world wine world which
is we live in an incredible democracy of
wine now for 15 years the white
spectator Robert Parker basically
dictated what everybody was drinking in
America that cared enough to care about
wine and now we're in a place with
people trying new things in America as
of ten years ago mainly drank six or
seven or eight different varietals and
and then a movie came out we drank Pinot
Noir and that made at night right so
like it you know people weren't drinking
different things I think that it blows
me up like I grew up in the wine
business and I tried to get my 21 22 23
24 year old friends in the mid 90s late
nineties to get into why do they have no
interest it blows my mind the interest
in wine for the 21 to 30 year olds
sector we're taking different wines from
different parts of the world the quality
of wine is greater than ever because of
Technology about knowing weather
conditions so I mean used to be able to
buy a really crappy bottle
for ten bucks no joke it's getting hard
you may not like it but to get a bad
bottle of wine for ten bucks is getting
hard you know with Argentinian bow back
and usually something Blanc and like all
these things so I'm very bullish on it
actually missed the wine business quite
a bit lately this is like a new thing
for me in the last I'm gonna get an
every day of my life from 15 to 35 so I
was burned out when I decided to start
doing the agency with my brother and
investing in other things but I find
myself gravitating back to it I've got
some things in my mind of getting a
little bit deeper back into it and so I
think it's a great time for do you think
oh please I can tell mine or done well
because because it is such a shared
experience a beautiful open a bottle and
want to feel the story do you see that
changing a lot of personal experience I
do think some people drink wine by
themselves no I think that's what's
great about wine wine is it's why it was
such a good business for me I'm a
storyteller and boy does wine allow you
to story tell I mean I used to I was an
independent alert my craft in the store
I learned that everybody in here much
rather me tell you about the golden
retriever that ran around the vineyards
and ate the grapes than how many
percentage of sugar was in the line got
it and so that's why my show did so well
right like I was able to tell stories
about the wines I was drinking and so
now I think that never goes away I think
- I like to think that wine was the
original social network you know it
brings people together
it is a beverage that is drank with more
than one person more than beer and vodka
but and liquor by percentage and so you
know I think it's got a very bright
future of being a connector and I do
think you know look Tennessee has this
state like you guys are at the
disservice of Tennessee laws around
white shipping so this state is behind a
lot of other places even smaller states
less progressive states because the loss
right because great wine companies like
my company wasn't
people to ship here for a long time or
kin or things that nature but you know I
don't know how much time people spend
outside but it's incredible with a rural
Southwest Northwest just wine culture is
exploding yes sir
good to see what's your name David I'll
repeat it for you guys over there I'm
worried that guys aren't hearing it
I'm in yes thank you so much let's clap
it up for the man that brought me a
present
man I need smart pants I have a feeling
I mean thank you thank you so much
that's very nice
sure yep
huge that's like a legend every Kristen
port yeah
yeah yeah man oh it's great I love I
love those guys by the way the markets
so big that they're both gonna win I
really believe in that
how many employees are you Hey
so good for you
any worried about the dynamic changes I
have some insights I really do this is
this is really my wheelhouse this will
ultimately be the somebody asked me
earlier today when I'm writing my HR
book I'm not ready to but this will be
the best thing I'll ever put out into
the world I know that effect you're
looking at an HR driven CEO I later
media has gone from 20 to 400 employees
in the last 30 months and I'm the only
person in the HR department so you've
stepped in [ __ ] I got a lot of insights
here's the number one thing I'll tell
you every company lies about how much
they care about the customer and how
much they care about their employees
it's really easy to say I care about
customers and my employees that was easy
right I think a bit like parenting all
these parents come to me like Oh Gary
like all this technology is so bad I
don't want my kid on the iPad for seven
hours a day I'm like well then don't let
them write so I may be one huge piece
advice if you truly care about the
question you just asked me put in the
work right for example back to the
earlier joke I desperately want a
six-pack right I don't have one I know
how to do it I know the exercises I know
the food I need to eat
I can Google everything I need in 20
seconds to figure out how to get a six
pack but I don't have one because I
didn't put in the work I am busy as [ __ ]
I blew away my friends that were with me
today because they saw that I got a
thousand text messages in the six hours
that was hanging out with them that's
busy right and yet I spend between three
six hours a day on HR now you and I are
the same business you know what I can do
in those three or six hours from getting
incremental scoped going in getting new
business right I really care about
culture I really care about my cut cut
my employees and look I start with my
employees I tell my my uh I tell my
customers the Pepsi's and G's and I tell
them I care about my employees first I
care about your customers on the
platforms that we create for second and
then I care about you and I and the best
part is we execute against that and so
the reason I do it by the way I'm not
Mother Teresa I do it because I know
another run vaynermedia forever and if I
wanted to do with Wine Library then I
need to build a family and you know how
you build a family you listen
and so the reason takes me three to four
hours a day your biggest problem is you
need and look you can have this problem
at eight
you don't need fifteen you need to know
what all of those eight people want in
their lives I spend all my life
basically it feels like trying to build
trust with my employees so that they'll
tell me the truth of what they actually
want to happen and I'm agenda agnostic I
don't care what you want I don't care if
you want make five hundred thousand
dollars a year and not work that much
cool you know I don't care if you want
to steal seven of my employees and then
start your own agency cool I'm not
joking I don't care if you want to be
the CEO I don't care if you want to
learn everything you can for me and then
go into a start-up and say you worked
with me I do not care
just tell me so that when we can map it
together so if you want to address it I
recommend you do a whole lot of
listening
human ah yes sir
on to my to get your text I want to get
a thousand a day yeah I just let you
know my god I appreciate it
I like I wrote it yes sir don't give it
out I'll kill you but if something you
offers you money take it happened
doesn't baby how are you man good to see
you yeah
to reach out to some of the people who
are here like the designer
yep
let me I want to make sure you get this
subscribe are you asking when when how
do you sell to a small business the
building value hiring somebody that has
more expertise or the way you structured
the question the first part when do you
reach out to other people that can
execute maybe your strategy I just wanna
make sure I understand are you saying as
a strategist around social both of your
problems are how do I get customers to
believe in the value product and then
number two if I actually get them how do
I find people to actually execute it
cool so the number one rule I have about
sales is not to convince anybody about
anything I have no interest in selling
to you if you don't believe so a lot of
people try to go and say hey Tony's
pizza in downtown you need social media
you need to do this you need to do this
you do this and Tony's like get the hell
out of here that's about where it ends
for me I have no interest in ever
convincing anybody that what I'm doing
is right because I'd much rather spend
all my time on offense and none of it on
defense
so I'd rather you turn around a thousand
stones than trying to dig deeper under
250 stones that you turned over got it
that's number one number two you know I
would be I think what you should do is
be knowledgeable that who can do the
things in your town before you ever go
to sell like you should have a fairly
good understanding of the three Lance
slash capabilities and rolodex because
if you walk in and you start talking
about turning over a thousand stones
like I told you to and you get more
yeses it's time to work so I would
highly recommend having that in your
pocket before you start
hey ready
that's right
well because the spatters table this is
not an all-or-nothing game right but if
you were asking me can I reach I can
tell you right now it's about with and
that right I could reach and then all
the hours that I've been here to get
here and all that I could have reached a
hell of a lot more people than reaching
right now but the human spirit is real
right like there's a book strap and I
have had a relationship six seven years
most of it digital right
I'm iPad I mean this how many people
here have known about me for more than
three years but have never seen me in
person before raise your hand so here's
what I think a lot about I did all those
things technology wise as a gateway drug
to this moment right and now I get to
make it even deeper than it was before
and so because they both work got it yep
do you see any trends and particularly
k-12 education I teach middle school you
know I have an app to text my students
and their parents but do you see any
trends for me to use with my students to
connect with parents anything so allow
me to like stand on a soapbox for two
minutes and I'll answer your question I
am yes here's the biggest trend I see
that the way we educate our children
right now is so broken it actually I
believe the most teachers that I know
that are paying attention do because
actually here's the problem we are
asking by formation I don't blame you
you've gotta follow though like I get
how it works it's not it's not
capitalism in the school systems we are
teaching our children to memorize [ __ ]
and then regurgitate it in a world where
everything they who's the ninth present
in the United States history this old
[ __ ]
that is like it is ludicrous what we're
doing right now we need to completely
reverse it which is they could memorize
the [ __ ] at home or don't memorize it at
all because it's never been less
valuable to be information smart than it
is now because anything you want to know
is right here remember remember some of
us older ones remember what it was
actually interesting to be information
smart that ship has sailed
I don't care that if you know something
I can tell you the same thing in four
minutes four seconds eight seconds it's
right here so you know I'm struggling
with it in a big way right like it's
really broken it it's it's not the
reality of the world we live in
it's you know the whole game I I think
that all schools should go to the
business format and like like you know
why teachers are underpaid because like
the structure go create a school where
it's complete capitalism and every
school's capitalistic and then the best
teachers are gonna get paid plenty you
know like I mean it's just it's so
broken it's ridiculous but most kids are
learning more on their own than they are
in the classroom because they have more
information at their fingertips
everywhere else back to your question
you know look I don't know the rules
every principal every superintendent
runs it differently like I love the
notion of you texting with every mom in
the class you know communications good
kids can't hide through the structure I
hid for 12 years through the structure I
just don't rip my report card up the
second it got to my mailbox and flush it
down the toilet two by three to six more
days of freedom even when my mom got
wind and punished thing for three weeks
that was the game in today's world you
can email me that you could send it like
think there's a lot of things to do but
the truth is what I would implore and
what I before my sister who's a teacher
do and some of my other friends my most
practical advice to a sixth grade
teacher is to try to build the
self-esteem of this too
to us that would be that's the thing I
spent my entire life thinking about
which is the only tool against all the
pressures that our kids face is
self-esteem that is be weapon and so I
only have one teacher ever that I saw
now we're winding my brain and realizing
what she was doing that went person by
person in her class and accelerated and
celebrated their unique individual
strengths whether a sports school
personality humor kindness prettiness
whatever was she built self-esteem and
that's why I remember ooh yes sir
yes sir old guy good-lookin bald guy
yeah that his beard is looking better
yes yes yes you know it's kind of like
the six-pack story like what can you
guys do to be more of a start-up city be
more of a startup city right like the
truth is what can you do some of its
serendipitous there's some gal in the
crowd right now who's got an idea who's
gonna execute it
and it's gonna become a three billion
dollar company and then everybody's
gonna say well this is where the talent
is right we think you know there's all
these lucky factors I think the best
thing you can do is you know the
government and which has a lot of
leverage in this question and the
private sector that's been successful
come together and try to create some
sort of infrastructure that allows for
sex appeal to attract talent to come
here
look there's something here's the
biggest thing that struck me this is a
compliment taken I don't like to give
them this is an icer not nice like
you're nice most people are nice that's
having a break it's pretty you're here
and I think you guys have a raw actual
advantage over other places that I've
been to that look like you where I
genuinely believe that if somebody comes
here and look at the other night look
downtown Vegas is amazing Tony Hsieh is
a superstar it's nowhere it's nice to
live there as it is here right you guys
have something here like I was telling
the guys and gals I was hanging out with
like do you guys have like a sorry
season you didn't feels like if you like
vacation here because the water like I
actually think you guys have a uniquely
like you were gifted mother nature
gifted you I would actually triple down
on that and then and then look the rest
is wrong I mean look vaynermedia is
gonna open a middle America office I'm
contemplating this city and I can tell
you right now
it's gonna come down to the right like
like like pop you know I'm getting
ludicrous offers from Columbus Ohio and
Omaha Nebraska crazy subsidies buildings
like Quincy stuff that I saw that I saw
that I think I think you know you can
only push it so far you know there's
only so much the government can do and
they can do a lot and then it's gonna
come down to the people how much you
guys champion for it you know I think I
think please yes
which is I think that's a big one
because not everybody has that I think
it's the answer I gave over there which
is there's no one-size-fits-all
you guys have to listen listening center
or when people come here listen like
there's a lot of Millennials that are
not driven as much by finance they will
enjoy the work/life balance they will
enjoy the romance of like any of you try
40 minutes here you're hunting and
here's the water and they like the
answer is listen like I'm a great
salesman can they listen I just listen
and then I know what you want and then I
can give it to you got it
so I think the answer comes in a lot of
forms and you've got a lot of resources
and you do have some inherent advantages
I think one thing you definitely need is
a direct flight from New York if you
guys can figure that out all the way to
back hey can you talk about vayner/rse
yeah that's our doing through that what
kinds of things are you looking for yeah
so they Marcy is a fund they started a
couple months ago with a very
interesting situation I only have one LP
one person gave me the twenty five
million dollars that's a very weird
person that you really know me is the
owner of the Miami Dolphins team I hate
with all my heart but he's an amazing
man Steve Ross yeah
yeah he wanted to do this with me and I
said over under one condition he's like
what I'm like Claude Lee I wish it was
actually the runner off to buying the
Jets which is devastating for an old
story um he I told him that I can't
change my behavior the reason you want
to give me money is expect on really
well you want the guy that invested in
Facebook and Twitter
in 2007 you want the guy that after
Birchbox got 80 nose said yes and it was
less than a 3 million that's 500 million
like you want the guy that invested in
uber the only way I'd know how to do
that is to make a lot of weird
investments based on a lot of my gut
appeal a lot of things that most people
will see so what I'm looking forward is
the feeling and right and that's like a
shitty answer right because it's not a
very clear answer it's a one person
subjective answer but it's the answer do
I believe in the entrepreneur do I think
that she or he can navigate when it gets
shitty because it always gets [ __ ] you
and your startup is the idea is
something I believe it do I understand
how can I help
that's a big one to me like what
inherent advantages do I have then I can
apply to this build business to them
speed up the process to victory who do I
know that can help
what's the KPI what's the objective what
do they want you to accomplish with that
why
what do they want you to let's say that
you knew exactly how to get every person
then the broader southeastern area on
more debate attention to you what is the
next thing that they're going to ask all
those people to do
yep
and you want to basically tell stories
that make students want to go there what
else when you said that too for the
students is there something else you
want the students
I get that when I got its raw state you
want people to sign up and you want
other people other features to come in
or facility people or things that make
you want to soon as to help you build it
by actually joining it and going through
the curriculum doing it and they're just
having the leverage of having a lot of
students to continue to execute what you
want oh good one yeah I know I can make
these things seem a little wrong um okay
well the good news is that's why social
tea is good right like you can do
Instagram and snapchat and vine for the
kids and you can do Facebook targeting
and Twitter for the non kids I mean
literally the book that you were given
is my entire thought process on this
subject matter you should read it twice
um nobody I think look let me give you
this and I'll leave you this I think
it's the best point and the most
important point and this is where
everybody breaks down the reason I call
this book Jab Jab Jab right hook is cuz
it stands for
give give give and then ask the mistake
that a lot of organizations that look
like you always do is every tweet every
vine every Facebook post is ask ask ask
ask ask what even works
gimme gimme gimme gimme so I would tell
you that you need a very good strategy
of creating relevant content that
provides them value that has especially
for the kids that has nothing maybe to
do it to school maybe just a [ __ ] they
care about if a school actually knows
who the music acts or the TV shows are
that they care about you've got a
relevancy that might actually work to
convert them so you need to become a
media company is what I'm really saying
melon awesome you like those guys yep
from a cold call standpoint yeah I think
the single best things about to come for
you which is LinkedIn is about to launch
a new product that is gonna really work
for you because you actually know what
you're trying to reach right you
actually even know the title that that
person holds yeah imagine a world where
you'll be able to put out a piece of
content to everybody in any area in the
whole country just Alabama but just
Tennessee just southeast where you'll be
able to put out a piece of content that
they'll all see in their LinkedIn stream
based on the title they hold so that's
what's gonna happen for the sales for a
couple years before they get tired of
that [ __ ] that's right but that's gonna
really work the other thing is for me to
be people here my number one thing is to
try to put the b2b magazine out of
business that's in your business if you
start putting up content that would have
showed up on the b2b magazine side and
you're putting it out as you as you as a
person or as you as an organization the
battle that was the last answer for the
lovely lady with the high school thing
the number one thing that all of you
need to understand that I didn't harp on
that there's an entire chapter in this
book you know it has nothing to do with
the thesis of the book but I still
believe it's gonna happen I wanted to
get historical credit for it is that's
really why it's in the book is have the
single person in here and every single
person's company in here will be a media
company you will be a media company and
so what that means disappeared b2b
endurance sales whoever you're trying to
reach whatever they're reading to get
educated on their business you're gonna
actually be putting out those
papers and slide shares and infographics
as a gateway drug to awareness
absolutely the best way to sell is to
teach it's and the reason the reason
that works a lot the best way to sell is
to listen to teach it to provide upfront
value the person that gives value first
has the leverage alright yeah
yeah open-open reset email in 1996 for
people that sent email lists was in the
60 70 and 80 percentile open rates today
are in the 20 22 so behavior shifted
that's pretty good yeah and you're
probably neesh it's probably about you
you don't have 400,000 people on your
email list and by the way how many
people do you have you know my share
right so let me give you the open rates
of people that have five runs or people
on their email list in 1999 96 percent
you know because back to like we used to
you might have noticed the body language
I've noticed it over here more like we
just read every email that's why we do
their back that and so good
no nobody's letting you into their text
who here wants to get text for your
business I tell somebody if they text my
killer man list building stays forever
Facebook and Twitter list building -
list building the theory of building an
audience and that marketing to them
stays forever if you went worried if you
read this book you'll see up front
I sell the thesis of no matter what it
goes to no matter where it goes why
might be see my list is up 10% open
rates in the last 12 months you know why
we made it more editorial and we're
teaching people about line instead of
every email being by this Pinot Noir so
the future of this building is we're
gonna learn a lot about this last decade
and we're all gonna provide more value
you know what your next email should be
I'm gonna give you a really good idea I
really hope you take advantage of this I
hope you email me and tell me I'll agree
your next email should be titled what
can I do for you I guarantee you the
world and rate I guarantee you'll get
more response and you'll also get the
insight to your audience what they're
looking for from you traffic yeah the
tires the protector I'm usually like
they think it all stink and get her then
it might not work out but this is
probably my favorite draft since the
2000 draft the kid from Oklahoma I'm
really excited about Saunders I'm really
into this team this draft was really
strong yes sir hey Mike Sean Ellis went
to Tennessee right
mm Reb sorry
I think it's happening now Nita batts if
you look at BuzzFeed and upward the and
things of that made sure we're already
on our way there
yes to your answer and yeah I do think I
think the days of disruptive pass I want
to watch happy days but the bombs just
left I'm now looking at a Ford
commercial or over the word the process
of the diminishing value is well
underway and so the reason if you look
how many people here familiar with
BuzzFeed raise your hands so use a lot
of you know no banner ads on BuzzFeed
what happens is every 10th 15th post is
brought to you by a sponsor and they
haven't cracked it yet either because
like Verizon's doing a 13 kids that
smell like crap right like it doesn't
make sense but it'll get there
eventually and and so native like my my
nation see we're getting paid it's all
product placement right like and the
miners have full creative control so
they're not plugging they're like doing
smart stuff but they know their audience
well at least some maybe they don't want
them to fully sellout but it's still
funny or interesting it's still got
something right so I think I think the
days of ads that bring no value to the
customer is completely in the
self-interest of the brand to push that
in your throat are diminishing we're
gonna have to adjust hi my name is
Monica and I'm gonna owner and operator
of a music venue and I'm just curious my
demographic changes with the shows that
I have yeah and this wondering is it are
the social media platforms niche driven
or do you think all businesses should be
on all social media platform I think
they're dish driven whether certain
better scale Facebook Twitter and
Instagram or enough scale that
everybody's they are so have to think
about that number two I don't know how
much money if any you spent on ads but
if you do you need to understand this
and everybody here should go back home
and google this term and understand what
I'm about to say the single best
advertising digital product that I have
seen since buying the keyword wine on
Google in the year 2004 ten
and nobody rebidding me up for nine
months is Facebook dark posts so what a
Facebook dark posts is is the days of
actually having to build a fanpage are
actually over you don't need to drive
people to like you anymore if you're
willing to pay breath the ability for
you to make a piece of content a flyer
then you old-school mechanics that's
right so making a digital flyer and
posting it to people that live in
Chattanooga that are eighteen to
nineteen that like Bill Cosby and drink
jello and like rain like the targeting
is so absurd right that it's insane Minh
and you will crush it if you know what
you're doing because you're literally
reaching the exact people you're
supposed to and even though it's
reaching a hundred thirty seven people
when forty two of them become birds you
want got it right guys I gotta go